the life of Altair was one of extremes
in all things born weak and sickly to
the point he was not expected to survive
more than a few days yet he lived to the
age of 84. during that extended lifetime
he knew the inside of Royal courts and
French prisons a Parisian at Birth he
spent much of his life exiled from that
City Once a close companion of the Crown
Prince of Prussia he was banished from
Prussia when his former friend became
King of Prussia known to posterity as
Frederick the great he often disavowed
his own writing and used a known 178
different pseudonyms for his work as
well as publishing his earliest efforts
using his birth name Francois Maria away
he ridiculed the debauche lifestyles of
the nobility he patronized yet engaged
in considerable debauchery himself
despite or maybe because of Jesuit
education he satirized what he perceived
as the hypocrisy of Christianity
especially that of the Catholic Church
Tales of his many Works made him
fabulously wealthier wealth enhanced by
shrewd Investments he became a leading
figure of the historical period known as
The Age of Enlightenment the historian
wilderand called the same time period
the age of tear in volume 9 of the Epic
historical work the story of
civilization Voltaire in his play's
poems essays novellas and scientific
papers argued against slavery criticized
organized religions and questioned the
legitimacy of absolute monarchies he
used history science nature and Humanity
itself to argue for the existence of a
Supreme Being though he strongly opposed
organized religion most of his life
included a battle for free speech he
wrote to Kings and princes suggested
actions which affected Nations such as
Frederick for gray who was then
considering war in Europe quote while
loving Glory so much how can you persist
in a plan which will cause you to lose
it yet he also wrote to the common
people quote the husband who decides to
surprise his wife is often very much
surprised himself Christianity he opined
ours is assuredly the most ridiculous
the most absurd and the most bloody
religion which has ever infected this
world yet he was equally dismissive of
Islam and Judaism over the course of his
long life his views changed yet he
remained unadulteratedly opposed to the
dogmas of religious authorities a
writing to Fred the great anyone who has
the power to make you believe
absurdities has the power to make you
commit injustices though he opposed
absolute power of government he was
equally suspicious of democracy calling
it The idiocy of the masses impossible
to sum up his life was one constant
questioning of authority of nature of
his fellow man and of morality his was a
life of extremes indeed
foreign
[Music]
was baptized in Paris in November 16194
the son of an affluent lawyer and Court
functionary who by marriage held minor
privileges in the hierarchy of French
nobility falter later disputed that the
man who gave him his name was his actual
father claiming to have been born in
February 1694 as the illegitimate son of
another nobleman sickly and slide as a
chart he displayed a quick mind and an
eagerness to learn his formal education
began at the age of 10 when he entered
the Jesuit college Louis Legrand
situated on the Left Bank of the sane in
Paris he later praised his education
highly writing of the priests quote they
inspired in me a taste for literature
and sentiments which will be consolation
to me to the end of my life I had the
Good Fortune to be formed by more than
one Jesuit all their hours divided
between the care they took of us and the
exercises of their austere profession
Voltaire left the college after
graduating at the age of 17 desirous of
making his career as a writer his father
intervened insisting his son prepare for
a career in the law the young man
resented his father's implication that a
career in literature was a guarantee of
destitution that we accepted at least on
the face of it his filial duties for the
next three years he joined with other
minor Nobles and ABBA is a title similar
to Father though not necessarily an
ordained priest and enjoying the
opportunities for Rebels during the
Paris evenings of his legal studies he
expressed his displeasure a writing of
the profusion of useless things with
which they wished to load my brain he
professed his motto at the time being to
the point in 1713 his father obtained
foot the son an appointment with the
Ambassador at the Hague as an assistant
there the young Voltaire again found the
attractions of nightlife more appealing
than legal work and started a
relationship with olymp donoia who he
called pimpet and to whom he wrote Never
Was there a person better worthy of love
than you his employer notified the
father of his waywardness and Francois
Marie was ordered to return to Paris
threatened with disinheritance if it did
not address himself fully to the study
and practice of law when pibet rejected
his advances Francois Marie decided to
accept his father's judgment
[Music]
the French King Louis XIV died in
September 1715 leaving as his Heir his
great-grandson Louis XV at the time all
of five years old a Regency was called
for to save the monarchy and caught
intrigues a maneuvering among factions
desirous of controlling the boy King
created division in the French
government Philippe Duke de Leon the
king's uncle became region supported by
allies among the nobility and the clergy
Louis XIV had distrusted Philippe
referring to him as a fan for onto cream
or a one who bragged about his crimes
for us while Marie while giving lip
service to the practice of law had
already begun to write both poetry and
plays he also enjoyed the salons and
entertainments of the nobility whereas
wit and often wicked sense of humor made
him popular he described himself as thin
long and fleshless and enjoyed the
freely flowing wine at the salons
regaling other guests with his poetry
liberally laced with heresies and barely
concealed innuendo directed at some of
them powerful Nobles in the Regency one
such poem described as very satirical
and very impudent by a contemporary the
Duke de Sales Amore led to the young
arroway's first Exile in 1716 he was
evicted from Paris to two his father
intervened with the target of the verses
The Duke de earlier persuading him that
the Exile be made to solution still an
embarrassment but considerably closer to
Paris while the Roa denied that he had
written the offending verses and begged
to be released from what was in effect
house arrest by the end of the year his
request was granted and he was back in
Paris once again titillating the salons
and their patrons with his irreverence
and his often boardy verses which only
thinly veiled their references to the
regions the Duke de orleor in early 1717
a group of bursters appeared arroway
denied their authorship which included
the lion which translated read a boy
reigning a man notorious for poisoning
and incest ruling the boy referred to
Aeon Louis XIV the man the Regent
Philippe duke deol it had long been
rumored that the Duke's late just wife
had died of poisoning there were also
rumors of his being in an incestuous
relationship with his daughter although
these were never confirmed the Regent
responded to the verses by issuing a
secret arrest warrant in Francois Marie
arroway found himself sent to the
Bastille in Paris without benefit of a
trial his first incarceration in the
prison began in May 1717.
foreign
ER needing to make the appearance of
practicing law while in the Bastille
arroway took to writing to pass the
weeks of imprisonment denied paper but
allowed books he wrote between the lines
of the latter one of the books he was
allowed at his own expense was Homer's
Iliad arroway began an epic poem of his
own based on Henry IV of France which he
titled La anriad he also worked on his
play edipur already scheduled to be
staged by the comedy Francaise in Paris
in 1718. during his imprisonment he
began to sign his name as M Arrowhead
Voltaire he also used the name to sign
letters that he dispatched the Regency
begging forgiveness and release it was
in that name that his release was
granted it was not long before that
Arrow a portion of the name was dropped
and he became known across Europe simply
as Voltaire he was allowed to return to
Paris in October 1718 in time to oversee
the production of oedipa a play which
included the theme of incest the
characteristic cheek vorter asked the
Regent if he could dedicate the new play
to him the Duke de Olio refused though
he allowed a dedication to his mother to
be read at the premiere the play was an
immediate Temptation in Paris playing
for 45 performances an unheard of record
at the time when the region had the
production moved to his Palace for a
Command Performance Voltaire was
summoned to attend as an honored guest
while Paris gossip linked the incest
Within the play to the rumored incest
within the Regency its author enjoyed
the plaudits of the man ruling France
the success of the play of his Henry art
and other works and essays brought
Voltaire Financial rewards critical
Acclaim and a notoriety that he
cheerfully exploited he was wealthy
influential and popular yet his Fame had
created enemies and his legal
difficulties were not yet over in 1726
Voltaire attended a performance at the
comedy francaise where he encountered
the Chevalier de run who made a sneering
comment regarding the writer's adopted
name Voltaire retorted with a comment of
his own while sources disagree on the
writer's exact words the gist of his
retort was that his name was being
elevated to Glory while our own would
bring his own infamy burn was not about
to let the insults stand he said several
of his harlings to assault Voltaire when
the enraged writer responded by publicly
challenging her into a duel which was
illegal the Chevalier used his influence
to obtain a letter to cachet sending
Voltaire to the Bastille yet again
Voltaire who by then had considerable
influence in the Royal Court himself
asked for a voluntary Exile in England
rather than another lengthy
incarceration and it was granted after
two weeks in the Bastille the writer was
escorted to Calais where he embarked on
a ship for England arriving there in May
1726.
foreign
was welcomed and entertained by
luminaries including the British satire
as Jonathan Swift the dramatist William
congreave and the poet Alexander Pope he
debated with political leaders aligned
himself with Sir Robert Walpole and the
liberal Whig party and attended
Productions of Shakespeare's plays then
little known in France in an essay
written during his British Exile
Voltaire wrote that the leading British
thinkers quote would have been
persecuted in France imprisoned Rome and
burned London Voltaire observed that
human reason was a native of England in
present age at least in all his
observations and conversations his
correspondence and his essays Voltaire
came to recognize the superiority of a
constitutional monarchy rather than an
absolute monarchy or a democracy as a
form of government he also came to
appreciate the religious tolerance then
enjoyed in Britain at least in
comparison to the intolerance prevalent
in France he prepared an English edition
of his honriad presenting a copy to the
queen and sold others on subscription he
also began work on his letters
philosophy sir La anglae philosophical
on the English in them he Express
admiration for the British government
the monarchy their religious tolerance
and their industry economy markets and
general Society the 24 letters or essays
contained numerous examples of
voltaire's biting wit in the fifth
letter which favorably compared the
Church of England to Roman Catholicism
for the most part Voltaire was
nonetheless disapproving as some of the
actions of the clergy to quote the
English clergy have retained a great
number of the romish ceremonies he wrote
and especially that of receiving with a
most scrupulous attention of their
tithes he was especially scathing on
presbyterianism and what he perceived as
its hypocrisy noting that entertainments
from theater to playing cards were
banned on the Sabbath except that a
person of quality and those we call
genteel play on that day the rest of the
nation go either to church to the tavern
or to see their mistresses
[Music]
in 1728 Voltaire was permitted to return
to Paris where he published and produced
several plays including some imitations
of the works of Shakespeare they were
met with limited praise though another
play Zaire 1732 was a rousing success
his philosophical letters on the English
were published in Rule and Voltaire
found himself once again in trouble with
the authorities they found critical
comparisons with the British unpalatable
forced to flee Paris to avoid jail or
Worse Voltaire sought Refuge with his
new mistress the Marquis De chateaulay
at Siri near the border with Lorraine
joining them at her Chateau was the
Marcus's obviously open-minded husband
the Marky de shadowlet desaj whatever
husbandly outraged the Marquee may have
Harbert Valdez Deep Pockets paid for
restoration of the Chateau Voltaire
maintained his home at Surrey for the
ensuing 16 years writing of his
relationship she makes me happy it was
well at Siri the Voltaire and Frederick
Prussia then crowned Prince began what
became a langsly correspondence and an
on-again off-again friendship Voltaire
also occupied as time writing plays and
essays on History Science the Bible and
organized religion he also began to move
about France and Europe more freely as
the passage of time lessened the further
over his various indiscretions during a
1744 visit to Paris he began another
affair with Marie Luis migno his niece
who was recently widowed Voltaire never
married preferring the company of other
men's wives for his Mistresses his only
long-term relationships with women or
with the married Marquis and his widowed
niece nor did he father any known
children though the Marquis became
pregnant in 1748 and died during
childbirth in 1749. his relationships
with both Marquis and his niece may have
been more platonic than sexual According
to some such would be in accord with
what Voltaire wrote years before at the
age of 25. friendship is a thousand
times more precious than love it seems
to me that I am in no degree made up for
passion I find something a bit
ridiculous in love I have made up my
mind to renounce it forever
[Music]
following the death of the Marquis and
debris visit to Paris Voltaire moved to
Prussia at the invitation of Frederick
by then King of Prussia but not yet
Frederick the great there while living
under Frederick's protection and on his
payroll Voltaire produced micromegas a
early work of Science Fiction in which
extraterrestrials visit us and observe
the foibles of the human race in answer
to a human's question comparing the
natural and the supernatural voltaire's
alienex bounds I say again that nature
is like nature why bother looking for
comparisons the alien observes human
reason is limited the universe Limitless
at the same time as he had in the French
Court years earlier Voltaire made
enemies as easily as he amused his
friends and patrons by mid-1752 Voltaire
was no longer welcome at Frederick's
Court having as he did so often
throughout his long life made powerful
enemies among the nobility and
influential religious leaders Frederick
banished him from the court though the
two remained correspondence as he slowly
journeyed back toward France and Paris
in 1754. he learned that he was once
again banned from the French capital
where his enemies accused him of spying
for the prussians with enemies behind
him and before him he turned left
settling on an estate near Geneva there
he published another epic poem La
Purcell the maid of only on in his
earlier oriad he had amid a national
hero out of the relatively unknown Henry
IV in La Purcell he lampooned National
heroine Joan of Arc and her legend for
the religious aspects of her story it
was banned in most of France as well as
in Geneva due to its frequent
licentiousness and near-pornographic
imagery Voltaire left Geneva and settled
on an estate at Fernie just inside
France where he lived for the rest of
his life
in 1759 Voltaire published Candide
arguably his best known and certainly
his most widely read work today atiro
Candide his mentor Dr panglass and a
host of colorful characters endure
calamities and Misadventures in a
fictional World Voltaire used satire and
parody historical events including the
1755 Lisbon earthquake which killed an
estimated 40 to 50 000 people religion
the military establishments War
philosophers charlatans and Humanity
itself are all Targets for voltaire's
prose dispatched with humorous contempt
Candide also contained a condemnation of
slavery one of many throughout
voltaire's Canon when the naive Candide
encounters a slave in French Guiana
mutilated in an attempted Escape he
gasps at what price we eat sugar in
Europe the enslaved victim gives the
opinion that if all Humanity shared
common ancestry is described in the Book
of Genesis then all were related and
quote no one could treat their relatives
so horribly Candide discovers a utopian
society dubbed El Dorado where he
encounters a Humanity freed of religious
Dogma a paradise ice governed by human
reason when asked if the citizens
therein prayed to a god he received the
reply we do not pray to him at all we
have nothing to ask of him yet to
Voltaire the seemingly perfect world of
El Dorado could not exist if all were
truly equal in all things as it is as
its citizens claimed then any discontent
in one must reflect in another the best
of all possible worlds for one is not
necessarily the best for all candida
derides the then popular philosophy of
optimism with its frequently repeated
observation that no matter how bad a
situation appears it is for the best
another way of repeating that it is
God's will when a man encountered during
candid's travels ask of optimism what is
that Candide replies it is the obstinacy
of maintaining that everything is best
when it is worst having observed that
life is full of thorns Candide arrives
at the belief that almost cultivate our
garden in the manner most suitable to
their own existence the book was
immediately banned or censored
throughout France as being Blasphemous
seditious and scandalous it eventually
came to be regarded as one of the
greatest works of French literature ever
written however he followed Candide with
dictionary philosophies dictionary of
philosophy a work he had begun while
living in Prussia and continued to amend
and expand it for the rest of his life
the book originally consisted of 73
articles in alphabetical order and was
later expanded to 120 entries each is a
subject of philosophical discussion
often in the form of a dialogue between
characters they range from adultery to
why and point out inconsistencies and
outright hypocrisies of many of the
positions of the government religions
and philosophers over the laws of nature
and the natural rights of humanity it
too was banned across France
foreign
in early 1778 the Aged Voltaire
journeyed to Paris to attend the first
staging of his play Irene stricken
Gravely ill during the midwinter Journey
Voltaire wrote what should have been his
Epitaph I died or in God loving my
friends not hating my enemies and
detesting Superstition then he recovered
attended Irene's performance in March
and enjoyed the Acclaim and Applause it
generated by the end of April he was ill
again he died at the end of May 1778
probably of uremia after his death his
political and religious enemies claimed
that on his deathbed he had accepted
baptism into the Roman Catholic church
and confessed his sins to a priest there
is no evidence that he did so although a
priest did attend him and urged him to
confess Voltaire apparently responded by
waving him away ushering lezemois Mori
on par let me die in peace there is no
evidence that while on his deathbed he
responded to the urging of a priest to
renounce Satan and he replied this is no
time to be making enemies this is but
one of numerous coats misattributed to
Voltaire including one which went viral
on social media in 2022 to if you want
to know who controls you look at who you
are not allowed to criticize such
misattributions play on the continued a
Resonance of the name Voltaire the
Catholic Church denied his Reigns burial
in consecrated ground in Paris another
indication of his refusal to accept
conversion is mistress Marie Louise was
the sister of the Arab distilleries in
Champaign and through his influence
Voltaire was buried at the Army there in
1791 as revolutionary fervor rocked
France his remains to return to Paris
and enshrined in the pantheon after A
procession attended by over a million
people in 1968 the first volume of the
complete works of Altair compiled and
translated by the Voltaire Institute a
museum in Geneva was published in 1976
the project to compile all of voltaire's
british's amount of work moved to
Oxford's Voltaire foundation in April
2022 the 205th and final volume of the
series was published according to the
Voltaire Foundation his life's writings
extended to over 15 million words
covering nearly all aspects of human
existence as was known during his
lifetime based on references in
documents up to 25 000 letters written
by Voltaire have yet to be found thus
there may well yet be some unknown pearl
of which recorded by Voltaire that is
pithy irreverent sarcastic and still
bitingly relevant